And the answer is that Y1 should be and
Y2 should be 2.
>From the solution for
X, we can tell that the basis
is the first two columns here.
So we'll go ahead and call that B.
And we want to perform row
operations on this, so
that we hit this part of the objective
value, exactly, and achieve equality.
We'll call this portion of
the objective coefficients, CB.
Setting up the linear equations,
we have that Y transpose B
should be equal to CB transpose.
And by simple back substitution,
we achieve the right answer.
We can check the answer by making
sure that it gives us the same
objective value.
So substituting in here, we have 2
plus 4 times 2, which is equal to 10.
And for the dual,
our solution is 10 as well.
We have 1 times 6, which is 6 and
2 times 2, which is 4.
And adding them together,
we also get 10.
We should also check the feasibility
of our dual solution by checking that
the bound on the coefficients for
the objective function,
behave themselves for
these coefficients as well.
And indeed, they do.
We get 1 here, and -2 here,
for a total of -1,
which is indeed greater than negative 2.
And regarding X4, we have 1 times 2,
which is 1 minus 1,
times 2, so that's 0.
And 0 is indeed greater
than the -1 here.
So our choice for Y,
was indeed feasible.